[Applause]
print Aryan Rita Ora reunite and it's
giving us all the fields the friends
came together Monday night for the Santa
Bali outtie concert at Hampton Court
Palace after last being photographed
together ahead of BBC Radio One's teen
awards in 2017 and what a reunion it was
I do love the rule family I love
everything about those Harry and Rita
looked genuinely excited to see each
other as they chatted and laughed with
the singers mom ahead of the concert but
it's this hug that really has us feeling
all warm and fuzzy inside well Rita
performed at the charity event
Perry took the stage to deliver a speech
and enormous thank you to every single
one of you of course Santa Bali is the
organization Harry founded with Lesotho
as Prince see so in 2006 to support
young people affected by HIV and AIDS in
Lesotho Botswana and Malawi we have
managed to raise thousands hundreds of
thousands of pounds from this evening
and every single one of you is played a
part in that so you have the ability to
have an enormous amount of fun while
knowing that you've changed a lot of
lives following the event
Rita instagrammed several photos from
her reunion with the Royal captioning
them in part it was amazing to see the
Duke of Sussex again and it was such an
honor to perform and to show my support
for the wonderful work Santa Bali does
the singer also spoke very highly of
Harry and his then upcoming nuptials to
megan Markel while chatting with ET last
February
he's like the cool fun Prince do I mean
all my friends are like since we've been
growing up it's like Harry we want to
hang out with area because in our in our
culture it's like Prince Harry is like
untouchable you know it's like a real
thing it's really nice to see him happy
and everything making descent